this video is sponsored by vita dao
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show now
over the past few months i've been
hearing more and more about
cryptocurrencies
i originally heard of bitcoin two years
ago but it wasn't until last year that i
really tried to understand it
and what the hype was about and well it
turns out there isn't just something
called bitcoin
but there's something called ethereum
and old coins and yeah i
pretty much fell down a rabbit hole and
the more i learned about it the more i
realized it was less about some get rich
quick scheme
but to me it was more about the
underpinning technology and its
applications
but i mean at the same time i can't
ignore the fact that some people seem to
have made a lot of money from it
however many want to do something
impactful with their wealth
for example you may have heard of the
creator behind the ethereum blockchain
and youngest known crypto billionaire
vitalik buterin who donated at least at
the time
around 1 billion to the india caverd
relief fund
and who has also donated millions to
other charities including the methuselah
foundation
a non-profit medical charity focused on
extending the healthy human lifespan
but here's just one example of many so
whilst i have a somewhat beginner's
understanding of blockchain
and decentralized technologies there
isn't only what i'm going to talk about
in this video because there's probably
way more knowledgeable people than me
who can
explain that in much more detail instead
i thought it'd be cooler to see how the
use of this technology could be applied
to academic research
how it can aid with funding for research
projects and how everyone can be
involved
whether you're a researcher a longevity
enthusiast a crypto enthusiast
or all three so in this video we'll have
a general overview of some of the
challenges that are faced in research
and what's being done to address them
and to discuss this later part i'll
introduce you to the work that feta
adele are trying to do
my thoughts in it and how you can get
involved now
as much as i love being a researcher and
i love science
there are definitely some challenges in
scientific research
none of these challenges are necessarily
constrained to longevity research
but scientific research more broadly but
longevity research itself aligns well
with crypto
since both have previously been and
continue to be dismissed due to the high
risk nature now arguably one of the
major issues
in research is funding because well
research is expensive
from the basic research that i do where
a tiny tube of liquid
containing some protein inhibitor could
literally cost thousands
to the endless usage of perpet tips in
cell culture media
these all add up plus there's paying the
researchers
building maintenance and then think
about clinical trials and how
as the scale doubles the cost can
literally multiply
in particular in the context of
longevity research
power comes in numbers and data quality
is so important when it comes to taking
more measurements
and then you want to have more
biomarkers and yeah that cost just keeps
writing
so i think you get the just research
isn't cheap but the problem is
where does that funding come from and
how much funding is available to
different research groups or
institutions
and the thing is funding availability
will affect what research is undertaken
which therefore affects what data is
published and also affects
how many risks are taken because if
you've got endless amounts of funding
you're more likely to be a bit risky
because you can
and the thing is if you've got limited
funding it will bias you to do safe
more predictable science that's more
likely to get published when you're more
likely to then get grants to then get
more
funding so then keep doing the same kind
of thing and so you will kind of end up
in this kind of perpetual trap
where funding really does dictate a lot
of what happens in research
and i think it isn't necessarily the
funding itself how much funding there is
available
but also how that funding is allocated
and how those decisions are actually
made
and what kind of criteria are used to
make those judgments
and so i've thought about this a lot and
discussed it with many different friends
and it seems that funding does come down
to the root cause of many of the
different individual problems that face
the structure that implicate scientific
research
so i feel like i haven't really given
too many different
problems that are in research because in
reality that really does deserve its own
kind of video which may or may not be
that relevant or interesting to you
but basically i think if money wasn't a
worry or an issue with scientific
research
a lot of the other problems would be
alleviated so
besides the fact that there are some
individuals who have accumulated a lot
of wealth through cryptocurrencies
is there anything actually about the
blockchain itself and the technologies
that underpin
cryptocurrencies that could actually
help solve some of these problems in
scientific research
in this case in the context of longevity
research
well i said i wasn't going to try and
explain blockchain
but i think it is kind of necessary to
do so
to understand why it has great potential
for longevity research
so blockchain is a technology that was
first developed for bitcoin back in 2008
and essentially in the simplest way i
can explain it without being incorrect
it is a chain of blocks that track and
manage data
in the case of bitcoin that would be
transactions
the metaphorical chain of blocks creates
the ledger
that has a complete chronological record
of the data
an interesting analogy is actually
cancer evolution whereby one cell
requires mutation
replicates and acquires secondary
tertiary and
so on mutations as it keeps the fighting
to form a tumor
with all subsequent cells having a
record of the initial offense
the previous mutations in that case the
first block would be that first cell
that got the first mutation
anyway another cool aspect of blockchain
is that it is decentralized which
basically means that
activities of an organization like
decision making
are distributed rather than a central
authoritative group
so you have distributed control these
fundamentals are why there is so much
interest in it blockchain enables
security
anonymity and data integrity without any
third-party
organization in control so hopefully
that wasn't too bad of an introduction
but what has any of this got to do with
longevity
well some potential applications involve
being able to use blockchain technology
to record securely clinical trial data
and dna sequencing results
and this could potentially be important
for achieving personalized medicine
but what other applications are there
well this is where freeza dell comes in
as their vision is to create a world
where longevity therapeutics are
collectively funded
owned and governed by the population
that will benefit them
feta del plan to be the world's first
decentralized intellectual property
collective
or to be more technical a web three
based decentralized autonomous
organization
so that's where the dow comes from and
the best way to understand all of this
is through the feta dial ecosystem which
you can see here
this ecosystem has an open structure
which basically means that it's
accessible to anyone who has
fee to dial tokens you can get tokens
in exchange for funds as you can see
here all tokens can be awarded for
contributing work
through expertise or from pre-clinical
data making research proposals or taking
part in voting
and this will help to incentivize the
community aspect
as ownership of the feeder dial tokens
effectively makes you a co-owner of feta
dao
such that you can participate in the
governance of feta dao
direct research and commit proposals to
photon
and so the money raised through buying
of these tokens can then be used to fund
research and commercialize longevity
therapeutics
and so after projects have been
submitted and the community has voted
over which projects to fund
the selected researchers will get that
funding and in exchange for the funding
they give intellectual property
ownership in the data that results from
the project to feed a dao
the results are therefore the assets
which can then be licensed out to third
parties for commercialization like
pharmaceutical companies
and this is done in a decentralized way
and so it's this ecosystem that makes
fetadal unique
it differs from the traditional norms of
how funding is allocated for research
vitadao will own the intellectual
property resulting from its projects
and to join you either contribute work
or funds
and the idea is that this will enable
early-stage high-risk
high-rewards longevity projects to be
funded with current estimates ranging
from
fifty thousand dollars to one million
dollars with funding decisions being
made within two to three weeks
ultimately this will help to build a
large community of academics and
researchers
via a global incentive scheme since
researchers get funding for research
and so it's important to emphasize that
the researchers are kind of key for feed
delta function but it's also this
community driven focus that excites me
about it
as it makes the research more
transparent and enables more people to
contribute
now feta dao was in its early stages and
so it'll be interesting to see how
people react to the idea
and also be interesting to see how the
system plays out
and whether it be better suited for some
research labs than others
as there could be a bias for labs that
are frequently used preclinical models
and so other labs that are even earlier
stages of research may be
excluded moreover it seems a little
unclear to me
what would happen in the situation where
funding is allocated to a lab that
doesn't get
any intellectual property that can then
be commercialized
and maybe down the line it'll be
interesting to see if there's plans to
fund people as opposed to just funding
projects
but the idea is ambitious but if
successful i think it will have a large
impact on how science is conducted
and as i don't fully understand the
underlying fundamentals behind fita dell
such as the web 3 based dowel system or
the underlying tokenomics
i don't think i can have a strong
intuition over whether this is the best
protocol for the task
but whether featured out or an
alternative protocol that improves upon
their pitfalls
it reminds me of a crate from one of my
favorite films ratatouille
but there are times when a critic truly
risks something
and that is in the discovery and defense
of the new
the world is often unkind to new talent
new creations
the new needs friends now just to be
clear we're talking about feta del hair
not eating dinner cooked where at
but as i've said i don't know how
everything will pan out but i am
supportive of their intentions and
excited by the fact that this could be
something extraordinary
so with that i'd like to thank fitadel
for sponsoring this video
it's great that they appreciate the
science communication i do on this
channel
so do check out their website video will
be launching very soon so you'll find
the link to their website in the
description
and i'd encourage you to take a look at
their white paper and go join their
discord and forum
so i hope you've learned something in
this video thank you to my patreon
supporters
and thank you for listening